Today, let's start our
little look at history.
We've actually
been here before is
sort of the theme
I want to develop,
because I want us to put us
back as if you are entering
the labor force around 1930.
You've just come off what
we call the roaring '20s.
And while you should feel better
because the economy was going
so well in the 1920s
and profits were up
and the stock market
was at record levels,
you probably don't
feel very optimistic.
Because despite
all this good news,
family income was falling
in the 1920s as it is today.
Most of the income
went to the top 10%,
just as it is today
in our society.
And then of course
1929 comes along,
and we get the Great
Stock Market Crash,
and everything starts
to fall to pieces.
At that point, over
the next several years,
if you were entering the labor
force or an existing, more
mature worker, you were
expected to lose between 8%
to 20% percent of your income.
If you got unemployed, over
25% of the labor force,
you were really in dire straits.
There was steady loss of income,
especially for those people
who were working
in small businesses
or working on the farm.
Well, this created all
kinds of pressures,
and it led to the election
of a new president.
President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt
was elected in 1932 with
pressure from the population
to bring us out
of the depression
and find new ways to protect
workers' jobs and incomes.
Well, he had quite
a job on his hands--
so many people out
on the streets,
looking for a job, homeless.
A new term was
invented, something
called Hooverville,
people pitching
tents in our major
cities because they
had nowhere else to live.
The Great Dust Bowl occurred, so
people from Oklahoma and Texas
started to migrate
with their families
to California in search
of a better life.
The Grapes of Wrath,
written to describe
the plight of these
people who were moving
to try to find a better job
and a better opportunity
was probably the best
selling book about that time.
And so something was needed.
Well, we actually did get some
change in national policy.
This is a picture of
the first woman cabinet
member in the United
States, Frances Perkins,
who was chosen to be
the Secretary of Labor
by President Roosevelt.
But she warned him.
When he interviewed her
about the job, she said,
Mr. President, you don't want
to choose me as a secretary
unless you're willing to think
about new forms of unemployment
insurance and minimum wages
and social security for people
when they retire.
Well, Roosevelt said,
that's exactly why
I want you for this job.
And so we did see what was
called the New Deal come
to pass in the 1930s, with a
lot of work with the Congress
and with the Roosevelt
administration.
And building on many
of the innovations that
occurred at state and
local government levels
in the previous 20 years, we got
much of the labor legislation
that still is the
foundation for labor policy
today, starting with
unemployment insurance.
Unemployment insurance
was first put in place
to try to provide temporary
assistance for people
who were out of work who would
get called back to work when
the economy got better.
Well, that worked
for a long time,
but today almost nobody
who gets unemployed
expects to be called back.
Job loss is permanent, and so we
need to update the unemployment
insurance system.
It's not just to provide
temporary financial assistance
for people out of work.
We need to help
them find new jobs
and get new training
opportunities
and assistance to move to
where the jobs happen to be.
In 1938, we passed the first
minimum wage and overtime
legislation, called the Fair
Labor Standards Act. $0.25
an hour was the minimum
wage at that time.
That has moved up now to
$7.25, but the bad news
is it hasn't kept
up with inflation.
So we are worse off
today at that level
than we were in the mid 1960s.
And we need to update
the minimum wage
at the national level to keep
up with the rate of inflation
and the growing cost of living.
The same with rules
around overtime--
through the '40s, '50s, and '60s
over 60% of salaried workers
were still eligible
for overtime.
Today that number is
down to about 10%.
And so we've got to
find ways to allow
low-wage salaried workers,
assistant managers
at McDonald's and other places,
to be able to get overtime
if they're working 50 and 60
hours a week, as many of them
are.
The National Labor
Relations Act provided
for collective bargaining
legislation in the 1935 act.
That law promised
workers a right
to gain access to a union
and collective bargaining,
and it worked quite
well for many years.
But today it's
broken beyond repair.
Today if an employer wants
to resist a worker's right
to organize, over
90% of the time
the employer is going to win.
And the workers
will be frustrated.
So we need to find new
ways to modernize that law
to provide workers with
the voice that they want.
We passed the Social
Security Act in 1935
that provided a retirement
income for all workers,
based on the hours
that they worked
in the labor force over
the years and the salaries
that they earned.
And that law still provides
a good retirement income
for most workers.
But that law, too,
needs to be updated,
because we're living
longer; we're not
able to cover all of the
debts of the next generation,
and therefore, we're going to
have to tweak that law a bit
in order to avoid going
bankrupt with social security
over the next 20 years.
All of these laws need
to be updated to catch up
with the changing workforce and
the changing nature of work,
but perhaps we
have to go farther.
Maybe it's also time to
pass some new legislation,
to recognize that today
it takes two working
parents to earn a decent
living for their families.
So maybe it's time
for the United States
to become the last country
in the developed world
to provide some
form of paid family
leave if we have to stay home
and take care of a sick child
or take care of an elderly
parent that needs help.
It's time to modernize our
labor and employment relations
policies.
So, yes, we've been there
before in the 1930s.
And we can do it again if
you put your creative ideas
and your collective
energy together
to modernize employment
policies to fit today's
economy and today's workforce.